&gt;&gt; As much as I love the new equation we just came up with, it took us a really
long time and a bunch of steps to get it in this nice form. It would be really
great if we could come up with a shortcut for how to get to the same end result
without having to do quite as much work. The information that we used to develop
our equation in the last problem was a point and a slope. Let's consider a
general situation like this. Let's say that we have a line, and we know that the
slope of the line is m. We also know that this line goes through the point, s,
t, where s is our x coordinate, and t is our y coordinate. I'd like to start off
by having you substitute these values in to the proper places of an equation
that's in slope-intercept form. So we want to start off with y equals mx plus b,
but then substitute in these quantities to the proper spots.